there's a lot going on behind the scenes
of Pawn Stars not only does the cast
have to listen to producers they also
have to operate within the boundaries of
Nevada's laws here are some of the rules
that the cast of Pawn Stars have to
follow whether they're on camera or
working in the shop Chum
yeah this guy's got pokeyman cars yeah
it's not poking man
it's Pokemon at this point it should
come as no surprise to fans of any
reality TV show that what they're
watching isn't always 100% authentic and
Pawn Stars is no different in that
respect but in fairness with the show
like Pawn Stars it would be impossible
to film a decent episode in a reasonable
timeframe without doing a little
planning in advance one of the most
important rules that the cast must
follow is allowing the items that appear
in each episode to be selected before
the cameras start rolling they can't
simply let people in off the street and
in front of cameras with the hopes that
it will make for good TV it would just
be too risky so when a seller brings a
unique object up to the counter the cast
already knows what they're getting every
single day many people come to Las Vegas
just to swing by the Gold & Silver Pawn
Shop in hopes of catching a glimpse of
the cast but as much as the fans would
probably love to hang around while the
crew is shooting it's just not possible
this is because the shop actually closes
well new episodes are being filmed after
all they can't have too many random
people wandering around the set while
trying to shoot as it would probably
result in countless fans attempting to
get their faces on TV and getting in the
way of the crew while they try to work
the shop still does just fine on the
business end even though they do have to
close on a regular basis for filming so
many people come by when the shop is
open that they don't really have to
operate on normal business hours to stay
open it's actually one of the most
visited tourist attractions in Las Vegas
fame does come with some unexpected
consequences and Pawn Stars is no
exception to the rule the cast is
actually no longer allowed to work
behind the main counter due to Nevada's
privacy laws the producers felt that too
many people were snapping photos of the
cast which meant that the people milling
around in the background would be
on camera very frequently this would be
a violation of their right to privacy
therefore to be on the safe side they
keep the cast away from the crowds when
it's time to shoot the show the general
public has to make their exit you'll
notice people milling around in the
background of most shots but those
aren't random customers who just
wandered it off the streets they're
extras who were already cast to be there
when the cast and crew were checking out
items that the sellers submit with the
hopes of appearing on the show they also
have a discussion with the seller they
don't just want to haggle with people
who happen to own interesting things
with a fascinating history they also
want to make sure that they're talking
with people who can be reasonable about
prices and actually go through pre
negotiations before potential sellers
get on camera of course every once in a
while someone who appears on the show
will be a bit unrealistic about the
value of their item and they won't budge
when the cast makes a counteroffer
for the most part producers want to
ensure that the sellers are bringing in
items that will not only be intriguing
for viewers to learn about but that the
sellers will be fair about their
suggested prices after all going through
hours and hours of filming without
buying a single item would make for a
pretty boring episode sellers are also
given some coaching so that they will
appear more confident on TV like most
reality TV shows the cast of Pawn Stars
has to work off of a script they can't
just enter a negotiation blind and tell
the seller whatever they feel the
writers already have a general idea of
how things should play out in order to
keep the audience entertained they do
their best to keep things natural and
make it sound like an off-the-cuff
conversation and of course they take the
personalities of the cast members and
their typical mannerisms into
consideration the script is supposed to
be organic rather than coming across as
stiff and unrealistic this all of this
planning and scripting mean that Pawn
Stars is really fake not really the
items are real antiques that belong to
normal people they just happen to have
been selected beforehand rather than
just showing up at the shop with no
warning the sales are real too but the
cast has already walked through the
negotiation in advance to ensure that no
one's time is being wasted the audience
is just seeing a polished version of all
of these interactions so the
negotiations for the show are basically
pre-planned before it all goes down in
front of the camera that said the cast
does have personal rules for
negotiations to push the outcome in
their favor
Rick revealed one detail to CNN when he
said
you should never ever give the first
number as a buyer you don't want to risk
coming in first with a high price the
caste knows that if they come into the
negotiation with an asking price higher
than the sellers expectations they
probably won't get the best deal that
they could instead they will always wait
for the seller to set the asking price
what do you want for it and don't be
crazy man I mean I got to make money
here - okay okay well you know I'm gonna
say like ten grand that way they can
work from there and adjust their own
requests with the aim of getting the
most value for the shop fans probably
know by now that this is one of their
so-called trade secrets as it's a
pattern on the show known or not it
never seems to stop sellers from coming
in to pawn their valuables even if a
certain item has an incredible history
and is still in great condition the cast
and crew can accept just anything that
they personally like before the vetting
process for sellers and items even
begins they have certain rules to follow
about what they can and can't buy for
example they can't take any items of
antique furniture as they simply don't
have the room for it
beanie babies are off-limits so anyone
who stocked up on these stuffed animals
during the 90s and hoped that they would
be able to sell them for a high price
one day is out of luck they do buy
firearms on the show fairly often but
they can only accept firearms that were
manufactured by 1898 or earlier as far
as sports cards go they are only in the
market for cards that were printed in
the 60s or before Nevada has some pretty
thorough legal restrictions for pawn
shops obviously there are plenty of
these shops operating around the Las
Vegas area but they do have to operate
according to certain regulations pawn
shops are sometimes seen as seedy
businesses so people might be surprised
by all the rules that the state requires
the shops to follow behind the scenes
the Pawn Stars cast has a long to-do
list a complete that might not be
interesting for the viewers to watch but
it's crucial to keeping the shop running
one strange law that stands out is that
pawn shops are required to keep a
physical description of every seller on
record every sale has to be thoroughly
documented including details that people
might find insignificant the pawnshop
buyers even have to give a description
of the hair color skin color and facial
appearance of the seller you might
assume that sends all of the sellers on
the show appear on camera the rule might
not apply but just because their
appearance was technically documented on
film
doesn't mean that the staff gets to
skirt that particular rule one of their
other crucial daily responsibilities
includes sending a daily report of all
the shops transactions to local law
enforcement if there are any legal
issues with the sellers and their items
the police need to have everything in
writing to deal with it
it might seem safe to assume that the
cast would be able to personally
appraise the items that potential
sellers present but that actually falls
outside the realm of their
responsibilities truth is I know very
little about it so I called you down
here because I just wanted you to look
at it and see what you know about it
in fact the cast doesn't handle any
appraisals if a seller brings in an item
of unknown origin Rick and friends are
not the ones who will help them figure
out what they have on their hands this
might come as a disappointment to some
sellers but the cast is more than
willing to help people connect with
outside third party appraisal services
and trusted individuals that they've
worked with before pawn stars regularly
brings experts on the show who are more
than capable of helping out after all it
would put way too much pressure on their
staff to manage appraisals along with
all the other work that goes into
running the business and the show the
cast of Pawn Stars aren't typical
reality TV stars one major distinction
between the Pawn Stars cast and the
stars of other popular reality shows is
that being on the series isn't really
their main responsibility they still
have to show up and work most days and
while they can't be behind the main
counter any more there's no shortage of
things for them to do in their shop some
of the cast members have other jobs as
well for example Chumlee spends several
afternoons each week working in his
candy store where fans can stop in and
see him on the job Rick also owns his
own bar Rick's rollin smoke barbeque
worried Bart ends on weekends perhaps
this is one reason that Pawn Stars is
still such a popular reality show at the
end of the day the cast still has to get
up in the morning go to work and do
their jobs well regardless of how famous
they are it's that feeling of
relatability that has kept people
watching for over a decade pawnshops can
have a rough reputation and it's easy to
imagine that someone who works behind
the counter would be willing to do
business with almost anyone who walked
through the door but that's not how
things go at Gold & Silver Pawn Shop a
fact that Rick Harrison has always made
clear harrison has stated that he and
his employees would not buy items from
people who clearly had too much to drink
in an interview with NPR Harrison said
if someone's really intoxicated or
something like that they don't know what
they're doing they don't know what
they're getting into and I'm not going
to deal with it I tell my employees a
drink or two is fine but if they're got
a good buzz going on it ain't happening
Harrison always wanted to illustrate
that not all pawnshops deserved a bad
rap and that his shop could show a more
positive side of the business he made
sure that everyone followed rules like
this for a reason he was a true
professional there are a few surprising
rules a gold and silver pawn but perhaps
the most surprising at all is the fact
that Harrison actually keeps certain
items off limits when it comes to sales
for example Harrison has admitted that
he held on to certain items for years he
kept several Olympic medals Super Bowl
rings three NBA championship rings and
more instead of selling these objects
Harrison puts them on display why would
a pawn shop owner hold on to extremely
valuable items rather than selling them
when he got into the business it was
actually a smart sales tactic people
would see this impressive collection in
the shop and they figured that Harrison
must be a very savvy businessman
speaking with NPR Harrison said it's
what keeps people coming back into my
store before I had the television show I
needed that draw we would always have at
least one Picasso on the wall check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stars are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]